did you ever meet
uh will smith
we can't get away you give me a little
touch-up
casper already right now
we don't need to know none of that
outfit is complete okay
[Music]
wow okay all right okay so for get close
to anybody that was in his inner circle
i know charlie mack who's
he's one of the best friends will smith
best friend alhamdulillah charlie mac is
muslim um of course we met jada pinking
because she had a very good strong
friendship with tupac and also tupac
mother i never met will smith personally
how do you think would he end up
benefiting like with his situation what
what what do you think with what just
happened with uh chris rock
it's javascript that was a nice one okay
i'm out here oh richard
oh wow
wow
will smith just smashed out of me
wow dude
yeah it was a gi jane jump keep my
wife's name out your
mouth i'm going to okay
i was sickened i was sickened by the
standing ovation
i felt like hollywood is just spineless
on mass
and uh it just
it really felt like oh this is a really
clear indication that uh we're not the
cool club anymore
man just you know it was sad to be
honest when i when i seen it and i read
about it and i even watched the video it
was actually a sad thing that you know
what i mean that it got to that point i
think he was it must be something else
in the inside that boiled to make him
want to react that way
it came out of nowhere because will has
something going on inside him that's
frustrated and i i i wish him the best
you know
you know a lot of celebrities have to
realize once you
become
on that world stage you you actually you
you and you were influenced on other
kids you were you're a role model to
these kids
you're a role model to these kids so
when you reach a certain level you're
not 20 years old you're not 16 years old
you're old enough to have grandkids it's
very important that you behave in a way
that you want your kids to see or your
grandkids and your family to be proud of
you
you know what i mean and i think um i
think he he probably gonna regret what
he done
i'm sure that he's gonna realize that he
should have reacted in that manner and
um you know what i mean because
especially the days that you live you're
living in a castle culture now where
they waiting for you to make any mistake
and they cancel you wow so will will
smith's uh what you said his best friend
what's his name charlie charlie mack is
one of the best best friends of will
smith and um and charlie mack is a
muslim he's muslim he's from philly he
muslim humbly he always be good at will
you know he's be good at will he's be
good if jada and uh and and he's a
person has wisdom
so it's good to know that we'll have
some people someone like that in this
corner
because maybe he can give him some good
advice inshallah so we're that's what
we're hoping like in these situations uh
because so many things come up when
people don't have the blueprint for life
you know do you think now will smith
would be able to benefit not just in his
marriage i mean and just in totality his
whole life with islam
may allah give him his diet you know
what i mean i pray that i pray that he
accept the religion of islam because he
have like he have so many people that's
close to islam that i mean he has so
many muslims that are close to him you
know so you never know guidance is from
allah you never know he might realize
that islam is what he need to put some
order in his life you know what i mean
because money and fame doesn't
necessarily equal happiness
you know what i mean um
islam is what give that peace that you
you know cement to your creators what's
the only thing that's going to fulfill
that void that you feel in your heart
and um so i pray that a lot may allah
guide them you know to me i pray he get
hidayah i mean i mean a lot of things
come up when you see this whole
situation you see rita you know this
this comes to mind you know with the
whole situation
uh that protective jealousy that's there
outlined in islam
you know how how were you looking back
then at women compared to now
you know unfortunately
did you have this uh
back then
bro i got latino blood in me i think
i think i always had this like this this
jealousy in miyake you know what i mean
um
um but islam teaches you how to have a
healthy jealousy you know what i mean a
healthy gear over your woman where is
balance
and islam soprano life is practice is it
put everything in this in in his due
place you know what i mean so but back
then i didn't really have respect for
women because i came from environment
that i remember as a kid if i had a girl
that i was i liked or whatever and
you know i don't want to go into details
as soon as my homies see me with her i
would start acting all tough and
disrespectful towards them because the
environment showed us that the more
respect you you might obtain is about
being disrespectful for women and then
when we went to the music industry we
kind of dragged that on with us you know
what i mean it wasn't really no respect
it just it just it was a very strange
upbringing you know uh i thank god that
i did come from a family of marriage i
knew my mother and father was married my
grandparents were married i had aunts
and uncle that married so i did see that
growing up you know what i mean but i
didn't have really no role model to
teach me how to treat a woman until i
accepted the religion of islam and i
started reading and learning and
studying how to profit how his
companions how they dealt with women
these were some of the most masculine
the most these are the people that broke
down roman armies the persian armies no
no army can come to them these was the
these was real men but yet they were so
patient and soft with dealing with a
woman
so we had it wrong all the time we
thought that in order to show us
to show that we are real men you got to
be tough to your woman and strong and
yell at them but we get from the prophet
and his companion is the opposite how
did he lie